in today's video we're going to be
explaining all luffy's forms in one
piece we'll start with his regular form
and towards the end of the video we'll
cover some of luffy's most interesting
transformations along with a special
mystery form at the end which you
definitely don't want to miss despite
his relatively small physical stature
compared to most of the world's powerful
fighters luffy has developed significant
physical strength to match them a
notable example of this strength was on
dressrosa when he used his foot to block
a stomp by don quixote doflamingo a man
nearly twice his height with the immense
physical power of his own earlier that
day he even effortlessly flipped over
the massive gladiator spartan defeating
him as well with constantly improving
skill in battle combined with his almost
unbreakable willpower luffy has found
ways to defeat increasingly powerful
opponents that have come in his path all
while having been out at sea for less
than a year gumma gomonomi enables all
parts of luffy's body to behave like
rubber meaning that certain actions that
otherwise would be impossible to do with
a normal human body can be achieved
through the ability for extra speed or
power furthermore thanks to rubber's
natural insulating properties he's also
immune to electrical attacks such as
those from the gorogoronomi electro and
zeus luffy has shown a limited ability
to move in midair by grabbing onto
something with an extended limb and
pulling himself away from what could
have been a fatal attack this gives him
the option of several jumping and
airborne attacks that would have been
disadvantageous to most other people
luffy can also use his stretching
abilities to inhale a great amount of
air to excel a big gust of wind this
application of his powers was used to
blow away marigold's poisonous vapor
from her venom spit and magellan's
poison breath afro luffy during the long
ring long land arc luffy had to face
foxy the silver fox in the final event
combat usual who was with him spotted a
big black afro and had luffy wear it
thus afro-luffy was born usopp claims
that the afro gives luffy extra power
while wearing the afro luffy also tends
to say things such as hell yeah although
only nami and possibly zoro think that
it doesn't help anything the others say
because of the afro is how he gets more
powerful but they're probably just
joking or playing along although this
form appears once in the original manga
afroluffy returns again in a filler
episode when foxy tries to get his ship
and crew back he's forced to ask for
luffy's help when doing so he hands over
the afro he had before and luffy uses it
to fight there are 6 more incredible
transformations to cover so let's
continue with gear 2 luffy gear 2 is a
transformation technique that was first
seen in luffy's fight against blainel it
instantly enhanced luffy's strength
speed and mobility prior to the time
skip luffy would initiate this technique
by using his leg as a pump to increase
the blood flow in all of his body parts
as a result all of his body parts became
stronger and faster he's been able to
heavily damage some of the strongest
individuals in the series while this
technique was active such as magellan
and blackbeard when this technique was
in effect his entire metabolic rate went
so high that his sweat vaporized rapidly
making his body look as if it were
steaming in the anime his entire skin
turned slightly pink and shiny from the
increased blood flow at first luffy
could only use gear 2 for a short period
of time because the accelerated speed at
which nutrients are used up depletes his
body rapidly having a faster blood flow
is useless if there's no nutrients thus
this enhancement also means reduced
strength and agility after prolonged use
due to this as pointed out by rob lucy
gear 2 hacks away at luffy's life force
dramatically increasing a chance at
having a much shorter life span because
he's starving his body though luffy
rebukes it saying that it doesn't matter
as long as he saves his friends after
gear 2 wears off luffy can recover
quickly by replenishing his body's
nutrients by eating mean later in the
impel down arc luffy demonstrated a more
excessive use of his gear 2 ability
being able to activate it at
conveniently brief periods of time to
save his stamina and strength reserves
for longer fights this is possibly
because of luffy's mastery over the form
along with his desire to save ace and
possibly a large amount of food he ate
in new common land at impel down after
the time skip it appears that luffy's
refined his control over this technique
as he's now been shown capable of
activating it by swiftly pumping blood
from any of his limbs without having to
assume his original stance luffy's
refinement of gear 2 led him to using
the ability in short controlled bursts
activating it briefly in order to use
individual ability specific attacks with
this new mastery over gear 2 combined
with buso shoku haki he can now easily
destroy a pacifista and take down a
fishman as large as watatsumi with a
single gomogomo no jet pistol
furthermore using a combination of haki
and gear 2 luffy is able to punch his
opponents with such speed and force that
it causes his fist to ignite bearing a
similar effect to his brother's
signature attack which is called redhawk
gear 3 luffy gear 3 is a transformation
technique that is hinted at during the
climax of the fight between luffy and
bluno by blowing a massive amount of air
into his thumb luffy can inflate the
bones of a particular body part making
it gigantic these inflated body parts
are capable of inflicting damage on a
massive scale being able to break
through walls and large structures with
ease before the time skip while in gear
3 it was quite difficult for luffy to
move while using this technique making
the gear not the best option to use
against fast opponents this is why since
his battle against rob lucy luffy tends
to only activate gear 3 only against
massive and often slow moving targets
whom he likes to assault from high above
in mid-air after the time skip luffy
seems to obtained better skills at
utilizing gear 3. after 2 years luffy
can seemingly control where the air is
stored within his limbs this allows the
majority of luffy's arm to remain as it
is permitting him to stretch it thus
allowing him to attack and withdraw much
faster than pre-time skip he managed to
enlarge his right fist while inside a
yaru kemen bubble when engaging kraken
demonstrating the use of infusing
busoshoku haki into his colossal-sized
arm to enforce its durability and defeat
the sea monster luffy is confirmed to
have overcome his weakness of shrinking
when deactivating this gear after
inflating both his arms and using
gomogomo no elephant gatling on noah for
a prolonged period of time he didn't
turn into his chibi form
nightmare luffy before his fight against
gekko maria and orz during the thriller
bark arc the rolling pirates helped
luffy become temporarily stronger by
infusing him with the power of 100
shadows that were separated from their
owners by maria's use of the
kagekaginomi this enabled luffy to
become nightmare luffy with luffy's
strong spirit he was able to contain 100
shadows within him when most normal
people could only contain two or three
in this form luffy was several times
bigger than his normal self and his skin
turned completely blue he was roughly
the same size as maria and his body was
similar to chopper's post time skip
heavy point luffy also talked
differently losing his usual carefree
tone and instead speaking with grim
seriousness by being further augmented
by the hundred shadows all of his normal
techniques are further increased enough
to topple even oars while in this form
luffy was capable of using the combined
strength and skills of the shadows
within him with this strength luffy was
even capable of stopping a giant
gomogomono rifle attack delivered by orz
with one hand and delivering massive
attacks onto the zombie behemoth because
one of the shadows belonged to a
swordsman luffy also gained the ability
to fight with swords something he never
knew before he also appears to be able
to move at incredible speed having
safely snatched up both nami and do soap
away from a rampaging oars and it was
only when luffy made his presence known
did orz and maria learn about it in
unlimited crews nightmare luffy also
demonstrated archery skills and could
shoot fireballs from his mouth after
drinking sake this form however only
lasted for 10 minutes after that all of
the shadows within luffy returned to
their original owners gear 4 luffy gear
4 is a transformation technique first
seen in luffy's battle against don
quixote doflamingo it was developed by
luffy during his training on rusa kaina
and has three different forms first form
bound man in this form luffy's
proportions become warped and his body
becomes much larger in size with his
arms upper torso and legs coated in buso
shoku haki as a side effect he's
incapable of standing still on the
ground and instead constantly bounds on
the spot this form was created in order
to combat many powerful and large
animals on rusa kaina it possesses both
high speed movement reminiscent of soru
and the ability to kick off the air
similar to geppel these moves are
cleverly adapted to work with his body's
elasticity it allows luffy to not only
bound off the air but also make the
attacks bounce off his own body after
bauman lands on the ground after using
an attack luffy can't seem to control
his landing and bounces like a ball in a
comical fashion until he either loses
momentum or he somehow regains control
and starts flying again though he has
some heightened resistance to cutting
attacks in this form if an opponent
using a bladed weapon has busochoku haki
of comparable or greater strength to
luffy's own they'll be able to cut
through his coated arms with relative
ease similarly his near immunity to
blunt force attacks is also not absolute
this was seen when luffy attacked kaido
and the latter counter-attacked with his
kadable instead of bouncing luffy was
sent flying and rendered unconscious by
a single hit tank man during his battle
with charlotte cracker luffy revealed
another form of gear 4 known as tank man
currently the base form of tank man is
unknown since the only time it's been
used was after luffy ate crackers
biscuits to the point where he was
completely full and used his manpuku
version for him due to the increase in
luffy's metabolism gear four causes he's
able to leave his tank band form in a
short time after using it this is the
case when luffy was able to burn off the
massive amount of biscuits he'd eaten in
his fight with crackers shortly after he
defeated the sweet commander in this
form luffy's arms inflate slightly while
most of the air appears to fill his
torso luffy's durability rises sharply
in this form as he was capable of
tanking and deflecting a piercing strike
from charlotte cracker whereas
previously cracker was able to cut
deeply into luffy's arm when luffy was
in bound man snake man during his battle
with charlotte karakuri luffy revealed
another form of gear 4 known as snake
man unlike his other two gear 4 forms
luffy does not significantly expand with
his forearms legs and upper torso being
only slightly enlarged and the rest of
his body retaining its normal
proportions instead of steam this form
produces a gaseous substance appearing
as a mix of steam and fire his fists
also flex differently which the first
knuckles being extended similar to a
leopard fist in this form luffy gains a
significant increase in speed and the
ability to use python to change the
direction of his attacks however
snakeman allows his attacks to
continuously accelerate the longer they
last allowing luffy not only to press an
attack more fiercely on an opponent
capable of dodging but also to increase
the attack's speed and power until he
finally lands the hit it also gives him
the opportunity to attack any area of an
opponent with ease this form focuses on
dealing with agile opponents who
specialize in dodging and requires
luffy's recently heightened proficiency
in kenbun shokuhaki in order to make his
punches into semi-homing attacks since
his body's lack of inflation luffy's
defense is considerably worse compared
to his bound man in tank man forms when
he was thrown into structures by
karakuri he took the impact like he
normally would as opposed to bouncing as
he does in bound men additionally he
receives blunt attacks as he does
normally rather than having them bounce
off of him we'll soon cover luffy's
mystery form but let's first explain his
fifth gear model nika sun god gear 5 was
created during the battle on onigishima
as a result of luffy awakening is devil
fruit in this state luffy's heartbeat
takes on a musical rhythm which has been
described by zunisha as the drums of
liberation his hair and clothes turn
white his eyes glow with white ring-like
pupils and white clouds float around his
neck this is similar to the clouds of
steam that accompany him in gear fourth
the amount of hockey released from this
form was enough that it could be felt
all the way to the live floor in the
skull dome aligning with the mythical
zoan nature of this new form luffy's
already rubbery body gains strength
freedom and durability that surpasses
what he would receive from his previous
forms to the point that it's now even
cartoonishly malleable there are a few
examples of this one of them is when
luffy took a hit to the head from
kaido's hasaikai and instead of being
injured his head wrapped around the
weapon another example is when kaido
smashed him into the ground and his body
squished and later returned to its
normal shape luffy is able to utilize
both the limb inflation in gear 3 and
the muscle inflation in gear 4 without
the need to pump air into his body first
he was able to increase his arm to an
enormous size in order to grab kaido's
transformed body and could easily
manhandle kaido despite his enormous
size swinging him from side to side
luffy can also perform the inflation
over his entire body at once
transforming himself into a giant of
massive size luffy can also extend his
rubbery nature to the environment around
him as see when he stretched a section
of the roof and used it to send kaido's
attack back at it this power also seems
to be able to affect organic material as
well as show when kaido literally
swallowed luffy hole and then proceeded
to have his body expand and inflate
along with luffy's he's even
demonstrated that he's able to apply
this effect on an intangible matter such
as lightning despite the strength of
this form due to inexperience it
consumes plenty of energy to maintain
and use this leads to luffy being
visibly aged once be transformed and
also experiences a high amount of
fatigue with that said luffy can
transform back by seemingly forcing his
heart to beat into the rhythm of the
drums of liberation despite all the
enhancements luffy is still vulnerable
to cutting attacks even in this form
pirate king luffy although there will
surely be a lot more interesting things
unraveling in the manga we can now
account for luffy currently having the
following abilities year 2 year 3
observation hockey armament hockey
conkerverse hockey gear 4 advanced
observation hockey rio advanced
conquerors and gear 5. it's safe to say
that he's extremely powerful and skilled
especially when you consider the fact
that based on in-universe time luffy is
only 19 years old the next logical step
for him would be to find a way to fully
perfect his use of advanced conquerors
as well as his gear 5th form luffy is
now able to go against the likes of
kaido simply using the little knowledge
of ryo and advanced conquerors he has
luffy as the pirate king should be able
to have complete mastery over future
sight which would make any solid
opponent physically unable to touch him
because he'd just predict their moves
his use of future sight or advanced
observation hockey will probably be as
good as katakuri's was during their
battle on whole cake island luffy by the
end of the series will probably stop
using his gear fourth forms because of
his new arsenal of abilities and
awakening of gear fifth the introduction
in gear fifth which seems to take
inspiration from early cartoons like
popeye and the gorosei hyping the
fruit's ability is only being limited by
luffy's creativity is why he could
potentially start transforming his body
into objects and vehicles in order to do
anything he desires one of luffy's major
issues ever since the start of the time
skip has been the drawbacks of him using
heavy amounts of hockey and while he has
been able to survive in spite of this
the challenges ahead seem more deadly
with the likes of world government teach
and possibly even shanks waiting for him
he will need to learn how to sustain his
hockey more and if not he might lose his
friends family and even his nakama
losses like this might lead him to
breaking down even more than he did at
the end of the marine ford and becoming
way more serious than his usual fun and
adventurous personality is certain that
by the end of the series luffy is going
to become the king of pirates so his
expected bounty by the end of the series
should be around 6 billion bellies which
is almost 500 million more than the
previous pirate king goldie roger and 3
billion more than he's currently worth
in the manga